was it the action the writing the side
characters fans who have gone to see the
dial of Destiny or seem to agree that
the movie got one thing wrong the
Indiana Jones franchise has returned
with its Fifth and potentially final
installment Indiana Jones and the dial
of Destiny the new film is notably the
first in the series history not to be
directed by Steven Spielberg who stepped
aside this time around to let Logan and
Ford V Ferrari filmmaker James Mangold
sit in the director's chair despite
Spielberg's absence the dial of Destiny
does feature the return of Harrison Ford
in the week since it made his Premiere
at the Khan International Film Festival
the movie has inspired plenty of
passionate responses now that it's
playing in theaters Nationwide a
conversation surrounding it have only
intensified too more the film has so far
been received fairly positively many
long-time Indiana Jones fans have taken
to social media to explain why they were
let down by the visual effects and CGI
featured throughout the dial of Destiny
on Reddit one fan pointed specifically
to the film's Nazi Germany set opening
flashback writing the horrible Siege GI
when Indy was running on top of the
train in the intro had me shaking my
head almost immediately in the same
Reddit thread another viewer wrote every
time they went to CGI when they could
have used practical effects it was a
little disappointing fans haven't just
taken issue with the CGI used in Indiana
Jones in a dial of Destiny viewers have
also expressed their dissatisfaction
online but many of the film's action
sequences in one Reddit thread a user
even asked I saw this on IMAX is it just
me or with a hand-to-hand fight
sequences edited their comment received
numerous passionate responses from other
fans including one person who wrote it
felt so claustrophobic visually it just
looked wrong most of the time another
Indiana Jones fan offered their critique
of the film's various action moments
noting we almost never got a chance to
soak in the set pieces because there
were hardly any wide shots it's not hard
to see why fans are going out of their
way to hold the dial of Destiny to such
a high standard either the first three
Indiana Jones movies are widely
considered some of the greatest action
films that have ever been made
ha
Steven Spielberg's Artful exuberance
direction of them has consequently been
praised quite a bit over the years by
critics casual fans and even other
filmmakers of course James Mangold also
knew that he was taking on a near
impossible task when he agreed to helm
the film in Spielberg's place in an
interview with Indie wire Mangold spoke
long and admiringly of Spielberg's style
and approach to filmmaking explaining
every shot has a purpose in Steven's
work single camera filmmakers who are
building sequences out of shots with a
purpose has gotten quite rare it's all
built on a powerful connection to the
movies he grew up with taking that into
account when he finally signed on to
direct Indiana Jones in the dial of
Destiny Mangold said he didn't feel any
need to try and reinvent the formula
that Spielberg had previously perfected
adding I had to screw my head onto the
idea that I was essentially a pinch
hitter for Babe Ruth I didn't feel like
I had to play out some sort of rejection
of his aesthetic I'm a profound admirer
whether or not the dial of Destiny
filmmaker managed to match the quality
level established by Spielberg is
something that fans will likely spend
years debating it's also worth noting
that Spielberg's only Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull Face similar criticisms
mangold's film doesn't seem to have been
received quite as poorly as that 2008
Blockbuster as some of the above
comments prove though that doesn't mean
fans don't have a lot to say about
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny